hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games welcome to the build of the week a
weekly video series that showcases
interesting character builds created by
members of the path of Exile community
when we examine character builds that
our players have designed we frequently
see a lot of good discussion and
analysis by a core community of
dedicated Bilt makers today's build was
created by Fox tactics who has been
instrumental in contributing to a number
of important paths of X or builds it's
very nice to directly feature one of his
builds in a video at last he has been
actively working on this character since
the new challenge League started so we
showcased it at a specific moment in
development his character can be summed
up as a vowel packed dual curse on hit
high damage pledge of hands arc build it
uses two copies of Arc
the first one is supported by curse on
hit and applies to crucial curses to
monsters setting them up should be hit
by the second copy of arc which is aimed
at pure damage it has spell echo granted
by the pledge of hand staff and a
supporter by faster casting increased
critical damage life leech and lightning
penetration the two curses applied to
monsters or Assassins mark which was
introduced in forsaken masters and
warlords mark which was substantially
reworked in that expansion they both
have a chance to grant different types
of charges when monsters are killed
power charges are especially impactful
on this carriage here because of passive
skill choices there's a neat trick where
this unique flask is used between packs
of monsters to refresh the charges if
they're about to run out the life leech
support gem warlords mark curse and
Durrani's invitation belt all provide
life leech the Val pact keystone reduces
the sludge total event makes it
instantaneous which is critical for
staying alive in surviving damage
reflection his enduring crane and mortal
call gems a hand cast rather than
triggered this requires more place
called a custom at the right times but
is more effective the character
generally has several insurance charges
up from warlords mark in terms of auras
the spilled runs clarity which goes with
eldritch battery and to purity auras it
also uses Arctic armor for defenses
there is enough mana that it can still
cast all of its skills were the four
reservations applied to its mana pool
pledge of hands is a key part of this
build it opens out with level 30 spell
echo and provides a gigantic boost to
mana which synergizes very well with
eldritch battery cloaca defiance offers
mana mana regen the ability to use mana
is a defense and the mind of a meta
keystone which saves a lot of passive
skill points void bring offers gigantic
critical strike boosts and can
Ramanna in the form of energy shield via
eldritch battery but increases the cost
of your spells by 80% the rest of the
character is set up to be able to afford
these high mana costs Donny's invitation
is very much a win more belt for this
build the life leech is very powerful
with carefully designed builds like this
flask choices are very important for
example this build uses topaz flasks as
an anti reflection tactic many of the
rare items used to crafted this is a
great opportunity to talk about a trend
we're seeing and how people use rare
items previously we observed a lot of
rares that looks a lot like this ring 5
or so good mods generally created by
either using chaos orbs or an expensive
process involving exalted orbs when I'll
say more rare items like this ring here
a regal log was used to make a magic
item rare and then a crafting bench mod
was added previously regaled items could
only get to 3 mods before exalted orbs
were needed with crafting benches
they're able to get to 4 mods so this
path is now a lot more powerful early in
new leagues in a similar way his amulet
was clearly crafted from a blue master
item that started with just a yawns mana
mod his passive tree layout makes use of
both the new witch and shadow starting
areas it makes a large effort to pick up
a lot of critical strike damage from the
tree such as the serpent stance notable
which takes advantage of his use of a
stuff several additional power charges
are allocated to synergize with
assassins mark whispers of doom is
important well our monsters to be cursed
by both maximal taneous Lee the eldritch
battery key stone is used to create the
vast quantities of man data this build
users finally a vowel pact is chosen as
an excellent choice against damage
reflection due to the extreme quantity
of life leech this character has Val pax
is incredibly useful even with its
penalty this build is extremely powerful
and has been created with items
available in the first couple of weeks
of the new challenge leagues it is weak
against curse immune monsters and its
use of life leech puts in a lot of
danger when it is stunned for more
information about how this build works
check out the guide in the accompanying
discussion thread links in the
description if you're new to path of X
some would like to play just head on
over to path of Exile calm or search for
it on Steam we recently released the
forsaken masters expansion and new
leagues with fresh economies so it's a
great time to get into the game if you'd
like to submit a build for next week's
episode just post a build guide in the
class forums on path of Exile calm
thanks for watching and see you next
time